jetzt ist es entschieden die Ukraine
bekommt Marder Schützenpanzer und es
wäre keine große Überraschung wenn bald
auch der Kampfpanzer Leopard geliefert
wurde ein Quantensprung sagen
Militärexperten nur die deutsche
Regierung tut so als habe sich an ihrer
Politik nichts geändert warum nun diese
panzerwände was will man damit erreichen
und wo sind jetzt eigentlich die roten
Linien darüber wollen wir reden mit
diesen Gästen
die jusuf-vorsitzende Jessica Rosenthal
Norbert Röttgen CDU Außenpolitiker
die zdf-korrespondentin Katrin Eigendorf
Nicole deitelhoff friedensforscherin
Matthias Gebauer der Spiegel und James
Davidis ehemaliger us-admiral und NATO
Oberbefehlshaber sie sind zu Gast bei
Maybrit
Illner
und einen noch mal ein sehr herzliches
Willkommen hier heute abend seit März
liebe Zuschauer seit März vergangenen
Jahres wird über
marderpanzer geredet das ist ganz schön
lang
wo war das Scholz der dauermänner vor
Eskalation vollzieht die panzerwände und
überrollt die eigene Ministerin in
vertrauensvoller Zusammenarbeit also aus
der Bundeswehr werden wir ganz bestimmt
keine Mader abgeben die vordergründige
Erklärung ist einfach der Kanzler hat
sie wiederholt bis zum Abwinken wir
werden keine Alleingänge machen es gibt
keine deutschen Alleingänge es darf
keine deutschen Alleingänge geben
macron beiden und sunack sind jetzt also
im Boot aber welche neue Strategie
verfolgen Deutschland und der Westen
wird denkbar was bislang tabu war ich
will mal Präsident beiden zitieren keine
Waffen liefern mit denen man auf
russisches Territorium schießen kann und
ich werde auch nicht dazu einladen das
zu tun
es geht um die Verteidigung der Ukraine
und das ist das was wir machen und
diesen Maßstab den der amerikanische
Präsident hat den habe ich auch und den
hat die deutsche Bundesregierung auch
nun also Mader bald vielleicht Leoparden
wo sind jetzt die roten Linien und wann
kommt der point of no return
Jessica Rosenthal ist bei uns die
Juso-Vorsitzende Frau Rosenthal für Olaf
Scholz Ware noch vor kurzem der Marder
eine furchtbare Eskalation warum ist er
es jetzt nicht mehr und warum droht auch
kein Atomkrieg mehr was ist neu was war
anders also es ist ganz klar dass Olaf
Scholz ja immer gesagt hat dass wir die
Ukraine unterstützen und die Kehrtwende
die große Kehrtwende Deutschlands die
kam ja schon unmittelbar nach
Kriegsbeginn als wir nämlich gesagt
haben dass wir Waffen liefern und eine
kontinuierliche Unterstützung der
Ukraine bedeutet eben auch dass ich eine
Situation vor Ort verändert und das ist
dann dazu kommen kann dass ich eine
Situation und auch eine Reaktion der
Partnerin Partnerländer ändern muss und
das heißt eben auch keine Alleingänge
auch das gilt weiterhin und ich finde
dass man das an dieser Marder Lieferung
auch sieht das ist keine alleine gängige
gibt und dass dieser Schritt gemeinsam
gegangen wird vor dem Atomkrieg hat der
Bundeskanzler gewarnt und hat auch
gesagt dass es nie zu einer Eskalation
zwischen dem Westen und Russland kommen
darf diese Sorge ist jetzt auch aus
ihrem Herzen
auf jeden Fall besteht diese Sorge
weiter und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich finde es sehr schwierig mit welcher
Leichtfertigkeit zum Teil nicht überall
über diese Eskalation gesprochen wird
als ob das ein Hirngespinst wäre in dem
Kopf von einigen
SPD-Politikerin aber das ist nicht so es
ist tatsächlich so dass natürlich
niemand in ein Buch gucken kann und
sagen kann so oder so wird es verlaufen
am Ende wird am Ende natürlich nur Putin
entscheiden was er jetzt Eskalation wie
versteht und wir halten uns ans
Völkerrecht das gilt trotzdem muss man
vorsichtig sein und deswegen finde ich
auch gut und richtig dass man abgewogen
agiert Norbert Röttgen ist bei uns aus
dem Politiker der CDU was lange währt
wird gut
ja jedenfalls ist es dann jetzt so
entschieden worden aber es hätte
natürlich viel früher entschieden werden
müssen weil das ein wirksamer Beitrag
zur Verteidigung der Ukraine schon
früher gewesen wäre und es ist ja kein
Sachargument das hinzugekommen ist kein
neues Argument in den letzten zehn
Monaten ist den zugekommen sondern der
Alleingang von Scholz der wird eben
immer weniger europäisch und bei den
westlichen Verbündeten akzeptiert und
nun war er völlig isoliert macron hat ja
entschieden hat ja keine deutsche
Entscheidung stattgefunden sondern der
französische Staatspräsident hat
entschieden
es läuft nicht mehr zwischen Frankreich
und Deutschland weil Deutschland
verweigert und dann hat er entschieden
und es gab die Gerüchte ist auch die
Amerikaner liefern wollen und damit war
sozusagen die Isolierung Deutschlands
kurz davor offensichtlich zu werden und
dann hat er ganz schnell eingelenkt und
meine Prognose ist beim Leopard wird
genau so sein wir sind dankbar dass auch
vom Spiegel der Kollege Matthias Gebauer
bei uns ist Herr Gebauer sie erklären
sich die Wände des Kanzlers genau wie
warum zu diesem Zeitpunkt wie
funktioniert die diese Abstimmung oder
funktionierte die Abstimmung mit den
Amerikanern und den Franzosen gerade
nicht also ich kann es leider nicht ganz
teilen was Herr Roetgen sagt ich glaube
nicht dass das ohne eine Abstimmung
stattgefunden hat wir haben das für
diese Woche auch also für die nächste
Ausgabe noch mal recht genau
rekonstruiert also es gab seit kurz vor
Weihnachten Gespräche zwischen das ist
ja dieses sogenannte quattformat also
USA Frankreich Großbritannien und
Deutschland gab es Gespräche darüber und
ich glaube der Nukleus dieser Gespräche
ist nicht so sehr immer die Frage Panzer
ja oder nein sondern es ist einfach die
Lage am Boden und wenn man mit Leuten
spricht die sich das ein bisschen
genauer angucken und auch mit mit
geheimdienstleuten dann kriegt man doch
den Eindruck dass man befürchtet dass in
den nächsten ein zwei Monaten doch noch
mal einen möglicherweise enormer
russischer Druck kommt weil dann zum
Beispiel die
eingezogenen Rekruten die ja mobilisiert
worden sind haben dann ihre zwar sehr
kurze aber ihre Ausbildung fertig und
eigentlich gehen sehr viele davon aus
dass Ende Januar Februar da noch mal
sehr viel mehr Druck aufgebaut wird wer
dann die Entscheidung oder wer das erste
Mal gesagt hat jetzt lass uns doch die
Panzer Option wählen das z.B haben wir
nicht rausgefunden ich würde nicht
annehmen dass es Olaf Scholz war sondern
es wahrscheinlich eher die Amerikaner
waren es gab auf jeden Fall diese
Abstimmung
und es war ein bisschen anders geplant
weil man wollte eigentlich gemeinsam
rauskommen das hat Hermann genau dann
durchkreuzt auf seine recht typische Art
und Weise und hat dafür so ein bisschen
die Lorbeeren eingefahren und ob das
Lorbeeren sind kann man sich natürlich
auch mit gutem Grundfragen uns ist heute
aus Frankfurt zugeschaltet die friedens-
und konfliktforscherinnen Ulrike
datelhoff fangen wir noch mal vielleicht
mit ihrem Tag bisher an sie waren in der
SPD-Fraktion eingeladen als Gast um zum
jetzigen Stand zur jetzigen Situation
auch zu sprechen vor den Genossen der
Fraktion was würden Sie sagen sind diese
Sorgen vor es vor einer Eskalation vor
alleinggängen vor einer dramatischen
Eskalation des Krieges da immer noch
vorhanden und
ja natürlich sind diese Sorgen noch
vorhanden und ich würde auch sagen das
sind sie natürlich mit guten Gründen das
kam ja auch schon am Anfang auf wir
können tatsächlich nicht ausschließen
dass die russische Seite irgendetwas zum
Anlassen nimmt um zu eskalieren das ist
vollkommen klar wir können nur nicht
alleine sozusagen darauf unsere ganze
Strategie aufbauen das ist ebenso klar
und wir haben natürlich jetzt Erfahrung
nach fast 11 Monaten Krieg haben wir
sehr häufig diese Drohung gehört wenn
ihr das jetzt noch liefert dann ist das
faktisch ein Kriegseintritt und dann
werden wir darauf reagieren und es ist
natürlich nichts passiert und man muss
auch ganz deutlich sagen dass Putin
jetzt auch sehr genau weiß dass China
von der Fahne gehen wird wenn er über
den Einsatz von ABC-Waffen nachdenkt das
hat sie sehr klar gemacht und
gleichzeitig haben auch die Amerikaner
in Gesprächen die sie noch in der
letzten Jahres mit der russischen Seite
geführt haben ebenfalls sehr klar
gemacht dass es zu einem konventionellen
Schlag führen würde wenn Putin solche
Waffen einsetzt die ihm seine
militärische Projekt Aktionsfähigkeit
faktisch nehmen würden noch mal zu
diesem Abstimmungsprozess was wissen sie
darüber Frau deitelhoff den hat es seit
Mitte Dezember gegeben das konnte man
lesen warum hat man jetzt diese Option
auf den Tisch gepackt obwohl sich
eigentlich auch die Amerikaner davon
zunächst zurückgehalten hat
also ich würde Herrn Gebauer hier
weitestgehend zustimmen es ist genau so
dass man tatsächlich sich die Lage on
the ground anguckt also wie sieht es
eigentlich im Konflikt aus und da
beobachten wir eben schon auch in den
letzten ein bis zwei ich würde sogar
sagen drei Wochen das ist leichten
Vorteil auf der russischen Seite gibt
wir sehen dass die Ukraine teils doch
heftig unter Bedrängnis geraten ist im
Osten des dornbas und dass man hier
jetzt auch überlegt hat dass man etwas
tun muss um eben sie nicht in die
sozusagen in die schwächere Position zu
bringen um dafür zu sorgen dass sie eben
nicht jetzt Gebietsverluste hinnehmen
muss und dadurch sozusagen wieder aus
dieser Offensive Position rauskommt
Katrin Eugendorf ist bei uns für das ZDF
lange und ausführlich von der Ukraine
berichtet und wird auch nächste Woche
vor Eigendorf wieder nach Kiel fahren wo
ist diese Optimismus geblieben der im
November noch in der Ukraine war
also wir erleben natürlich in der
Ukraine mit dem weiteren Verlauf des
Krieges und der ist ja in diesem Winter
noch mal ganz ganz deutlich vor allem
für die Zivilbevölkerung eskaliert einen
zunehmenden Frust auch natürlich was den
Umgang des Westens mit dem Land angeht
wir sind uns ja alle darüber einig in
der Analyse dass wir es hier mit einer
massiv gefährlichen Lage für die
sicherheitsordnung Europas zu tun haben
wahrscheinlich die gefährlichste Lage
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg die Frage ist
nur welche Konsequenzen ziehen wir
darauf und daraus und was die Ukrainer
glaube ich so massiv frustriert ist
dass wir im Prinzip nicht zu einer
beherzten Lösung kommen weil die
beherzte Lösung aus ihrer Konsequenz
kann ja eigentlich nur darin bestehendes
Land mit Waffen zu unterstützen ohne
Waffen Unterstützung ist die Ukraine
nicht in der Lage diesen Angriffskrieg
diesen Vernichtungskrieg gegen Irland
abzuwehren und wenn man mal als
Journalist auch was ich ja oft gemacht
habe an der Front ist und sieht wieder
gekämpft werden wird von ukrainischen
Soldaten die teilweise wirklich nur
Kalaschnikow haben sich in
Schützengräben eingraben und von
russischer Artillerie beschossen werden
da fühlt man sich ja wirklich an den an
den Ersten Weltkrieg erinnert also im
Westen nichts Neues da braucht man gar
nicht in die Kinos zu gehen das kann man
in der Ukraine im Moment ganz real
erleben das ist ein Schlachten was wir
da was wir da als Journalisten sehen er
würde mir silensky hat sich gefreut über
diese angekündigte Lieferung der
zunächst ja spät-panzer zum allerersten
Mal gäbe es westliche Panzer und das sei
für Deutschland ein sehr bedeutender
Schritt die Freude in Kiefer
offensichtlich aber groß natürlich ist
die Freude in Kiew groß weil ich denke
erstens mal
sind die Ukrainer im Verlauf des Krieges
realistisch genug geworden dass sie
wissen mit ihren Maximalforderungen
werden sie sowieso so schnell nicht
durchdringen das heißt jeder Schritt
jede weitere Bewaffnung ist natürlich
ein Vorteil rettet im defacto einfach
auch Menschenleben wenn man sich jetzt
anguckt mit welcher bitterter Härte die
Kämpfe jetzt gerade um bachmut geführt
werden wie Russland dort auch Söldner
einsetzt die teilweise aus
Strafgefangenen Lagern kommen ja
kriminelle Mörder Psychopathen also die
Lage kann man wirklich sich nicht
schlimm genug vorstellen und von daher
ist für die Ukraine jede Form von
Bewaffnung einfach etwas was sie was sie
natürlich
mit großer Freude aufnehmen aber es
reicht nicht es reicht nicht ich begrüße
in Jacksonville Florida jetzt james ist
und das liebe Zuschauer ist der Mann
er ist einer der Top militär-experten
der USA Admiral ade James Davidis von
2009 bis 2013
nato-oberbefehlshaber in Europa er war
im Gespräch als Vize von Hillary Clinton
und als Außenminister von Donald Trump
Stories hatte beide Male Glück doch
nicht nur Washington und Brüssel kennt
er gut als hochrangiger Militär war er
auch Auffüllung mit den Russen
erste Frage Admiral was wissen sie ist
ist also Joe Biden zu verdanken dass die
Deutschen jetzt Panzer liefern
dem Weißen Haus überlassen die
Motivation zu erläutern aber ich glaube
in dem gesamten Konflikt hat das Weiße
Haus sich sehr stark angestrengt und
auch Präsident beiden hat sich
persönlich sehr stark dafür eingesetzt
um transatlantische Allianzen aufrecht
zu halten und auch die Einheit zwischen
den Vereinigten Staaten natürlich auch
Kanada auf unserer Seite des Atlantiks
aufrecht zu halten mit unseren
NATO-Partnern und ich glaube das ist
bislang auch sehr erfolgreich gewesen
mit Blick auf die Waffensysteme selbst
ist es so dass der Zusatz von Panzern
glaube ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt wirklich
von kritischer Wichtigkeit ist und zwar
aus den Gründen die einige ihrer Gäste
schon sehr gut formuliert haben nämlich
vor dem Hintergrund der russischen
Mobilisierung und im anstehenden
Frühling wird es dann zusätzliche
Truppen geben die sind nicht besonders
gut ausgebildet oder sehr kompetent aber
die Quantität wird sich dann selbst in
eine Qualität übersetzen wie man sagt
und deswegen ist diese Art von
Bewaffnung ob das nun deutsche
französische oder polnische Panzer sind
ob das vielleicht
US-amerikanische Schützenpanzer sind
oder Bradleys wir reden auch über den
Striker das ist auch ein ziemlich gut
einsatzfähiges Fahrzeug das würde dazu
führen dass für die Ukraine selbst die
Aufgabe sehr viel einfacher würde wenn
Sie sich mit diesen Herausforderungen
auseinandersetzen müssen und wir
konzentrieren wir uns im Augenblick
natürlich auch auf den Bodenkampf der
dort stattfindet aber es gibt ja auch
noch einen Kampf der im Himmel über der
Ukraine sich entwickelt und da ist Putin
erfolgreicher als er das auf dem Boden
war bislang und deswegen braucht es
zusätzlich zu dieser Art von Boden
Unterstützung und Bewaffnung über die
wir heute abend diskutieren eben auch
den Versuch weiter die Ukraine auch
dabei zu unterstützen dass sie ihren
Himmel über der Ukraine schließen können
das ist ein Satz den auch Präsident sind
benutzt hat das hieße beispielsweise
Batterien die von den Vereinigten
Staaten geliefert werden und dann auch
von Deutschland vielleicht der Schlüssel
ist hier wirklich dass es ein
einheitliche Anstrengung gibt die darauf
ausgerichtet ist dass auf Land aber auch
in dem Luftkampf also wenigstens Abwehr
Defensive Fähigkeiten gibt und dass all
diese Systeme auf eine Art und Weise zur
Verfügung gestellt werden die die
Ukraine nicht dazu ermutigen dann
Schläge auf russisches Territorium
auszuführen das wäre sehr gefährlich
aber sich selbst und der territorin zu
verteidigen ihr Territorium zurück zu
gewinnen ich glaube das ist tatsächlich
ein Ambition die würdig ist für die
Natur für Deutschland und die
Vereinigten Staaten sie wissen
sicherlich dass es natürlich auch
Militärexperten gibt die mit ihrer
Argumentation am Himmel ist Putin stark
und am Boden sind ist die Ukraine nun
Kampfjets fordern dieser Forderung
schließen sie sich offensichtlich nicht
an
ich denke schon dass die Ukraine
Kampfflugzeuge braucht und ich gebe
Ihnen zwei Möglichkeiten als ein während
die Mick 29 aus Polen die Ukraine wissen
jetzt wie sie die bedienen können und
sollen die könnten direkt an die Ukraine
geliefert werden und die könnten dann
unterstützt werden durch F16 von den
Vereinigten Staaten denn über einen
zweiten komplizierteren Pfad der mehr
Zeit bräuchte das wäre beispielsweise
dass man ukrainische Piloten darin
ausbildet die F 16 zu fliegen das ist
ein relativ einfaches Flugzeug das kann
man gut lernen die ukrainische Luftwaffe
hat bereits eine tolle Arbeit hier
geleistet als es darum ging nicht nur
diese Systeme die ich gerade
angesprochen habe zu nutzen Patrick
Systeme beispielsweise sondern aus
meiner Perspektive und aus der
militärischen Perspektive würde ich auch
dafür mich aussprechen eben
Kampfflugzeuge zu liefern das ist
interessant können Sie uns erklären Herr
Stephen warum das alles ist jetzt
erwogen wird interessanterweise sammelt
offensichtlich der deutsche
Bundeskanzler all die internationale
Kritik dass man damit einer Salamitaktik
unterwegs ist aber auch die Amerikaner
haben ja lange gezögert ihre Panzer zu
schicken auch die Franzosen haben lange
gezögert warum erst jetzt diese
konzertierte Aktion
es ist genau die richtige Frage die sie
da stehen und bei vielen auf dieser
Seite des Atlantiks ist es so dass
ziemlich aggressive Standpunkte
formuliert wurden und das ist auch eine
entsprechende Kritik an der beiden
Administration Grab und da lautete die
Kritik dass alles immer nur schrittweise
passiert ist und das ist wirklich zu
lange gedauert hat bis man da diese
nächste Salami Scheibe abgeschnitten hat
wie sie das gerade formuliert haben und
ich glaube das ist durchaus ein
berechtigte Kritik und was ich jetzt bei
dieser Gleichung verändert hat wenn Sie
wollen ist die Tatsache dass Putin sich
immer mehr
verfestigt hat in den Positionen wo sie
sind und das ist immer mehr direkte
Kriegsverbrechen gegen die Bevölkerung
der Ukraine gibt und das ist auch eine
Massen Mobilisierung gibt die
vorbereitet wird für eine
Frühlingsoffensive und ich glaube wenn
man diese drei Punkte kombiniert dann
bedeutet das dass es ganz signifikanten
Druck auf Berlin auf Washington auf
Paris und auch auf Warschau gibt um
genau diese Waffensysteme zur Verfügung
zu stellen damit die ganze Sache sich
nicht zum Nachteil der Ukraine
entwickelt wofür röstet der Westen die
Ukraine jetzt gerade aus Historie das
können sie noch mal versuchen das zu
formulieren rüsten wir die Ukraine aus
Umstand zu halten oder um rückgewinne zu
ermöglichen für die Ukraine
die weapon System und die Waffensysteme
die wir der Ukraine zur Verfügung
stellen sind nicht nur defensiver Art
sie können auch für Angriffe genutzt
werden um beispielsweise
die russischen Truppen aus den
Territorien wieder zu vertreiben die sie
bislang eingenommen haben das wird ein
sehr schwerer Kampf für die Ukraine aber
sie haben gezeigt dass sie die nötige
Entschlossenheit haben und sie kämpfen
für ihr Land stellen Sie sich einmal vor
wie es für sie wäre an der Frontlinie
der Ukraine zu kämpfen und sie drehen
sich um und sie schauen hinter sich von
dieser Frontlinie nach hinten was sehen
Sie dann sie sehen ihre eigenen Kinder
sie sehen ihre Familie sie sehen ihre
Eltern ihre
älteren Verwandten ihre Städte und diese
Menschen dort kämpfen für all das was
ihm wichtig ist auf der russischen Seite
ist es so dass wenn die Soldaten die
russischen Soldaten sich umbringen wen
sehen sie da eine Diktator in Moskau sie
sehen eine Invasion die das Völkerrecht
gebrochen hat sie sehen schlechte
Generäle und sie sehen einen nicht
besonders effektive Logistik das heißt
im Laufe der Zeit werden die Ukraine mit
den richtigen Werk in der Lage sein sich
in dieser Situation weiter vorwärts zu
bewegen und unsere Aufgabe besteht darin
den Ukrainern genau diese Werkzeuge zu
geben damit sie dann auch letztlich
irgendwann auf glaubwürdige und starke
Art und Weise in Verhandlungen gehen
können um das letztendlich mit Russland
auch dann verhandeln zu können wirklich
haben nicht vor Russland zu investieren
oder zu zerstören oder aber zu
unterdrücken wir wollen nur das Ukraine
ganz und frei ist so und vielleicht
haben wir jetzt die Gelegenheit noch mal
zwei Nachfragen hier auch in der Runde
zu stellen Herr Gebauer für wie
realistisch halten sie das dass es
tatsächlich gelingen würde mit den
Leopard Panzern die die Polen nun
bereitstellen wollen mit anderen
Partnern hier in Europa die der
Bundeskanzler genehmigen muss wenn wir
gleich noch diskutieren an der Situation
der Ukraine nennenswert etwas zu
verändern ist das dann genau die Wende
die wir versuchen als eine konzise
Politik darzustellen
also rein militärisch muss man sagen ist
das vermutlich nicht der Fall der nur
mal eine Kenngröße sozusagen also die
Bundesregierung hat sich jetzt ja
entschieden einen Panzergrenadier
bitterbataillon auszustatten mit 40
mörderpanzern wenn sie Militärs dazu
befragen dann wird die Militär ungefähr
sagen so ein panzergrenadierbild der
Bataillon das steht so an der Front drei
bis fünf Kilometer an der Frontlinie
kann das Abdecken wenn Sie sich jetzt
die Frontlinie angucken ist die 1600 km
sowas das müsstest du wahrscheinlich
noch genauer sagen also wo aber es sind
auf jeden Fall mehrere 100 km das heißt
es ist keine Wände aber es ist ja und
ich glaube das wird immer so ein
bisschen vergessen in der Debatte dieser
die Entscheidung jetzt die ja der
Bundesregierung auch sehr schwer
gefahren ist auch den anderen
Regierungen übrigens glaube ich ähm ist
ja im Prinzip nur ein Anfang das ist
sozusagen er ist jetzt ein Tor
aufgestoßen worden was natürlich weitere
Entscheidungen danach sich ziehen wird
und das ist glaube ich die wichtige
sozusagen Nachricht die aus dieser
panzerwände vorgeht dass man sozusagen
diesen Hemmschuh wir wollen keine Panzer
liefern oder keine westlichen modernen
Panzer der ist jetzt weg und dadurch
sozusagen kann die Ukraine mit mehr
Nachschub rechnen und ich glaube das ist
auch glaubhafte dass die Bundesregierung
das leisten wird und auch die anderen
Partner und das stärkt natürlich auch
die Moral der Ukraine und ich glaube so
diese Mischung sozusagen wenn das
gelingen würde die Ukrainer zumindestens
so stark zu unterstützen dass sie einen
neuen Push der Russen ins Land weiter
rein oder möglicherweise sogar auf Kiew
da ist nichts ausgeschlossen das wäre
schon ein großer Erfolg ich weiß es ist
jetzt kein da sind wir jetzt noch nicht
in der Phase wo wir dann über
Verhandlungen reden sondern es geht im
Moment hauptsächlich nur darum dass die
ihre Linien halten können und wir fragen
nach Frankfurt Ulrike deitelhoff noch
mal nach dem amerikanischen Generalstabs
Chef Marc Milly das würde ich
anschließend gerne auch noch jam fragen
der hat interessanterweise im November
sich sehr kritisch zu einem Sieg der
Ukraine geäußert und der
Wahrscheinlichkeit kommt hier
die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
ukrainischen militärischen Sieges der
darin besteht die Russen aus der
gesamten Ukraine zu vertreiben
einschließlich der von Ihnen als Krim
bezeichneten Region ist militärisch
gesehen nicht sehr hoch
US-amerikanische Generalstab
s werden Nicole datelhoff und hier ist
die Frage
macht das nicht deutlich dass es
tatsächlich auf Messerschneide steht und
das auch gar nicht sicher ist dass der
Westen die Ukraine erfolgreich
unterstützen wird
also zumindest wissen wir es nicht genau
und wir haben einfach verschiedene
Probleme das eine ist wir können nicht
so gut hinter diesen Vorhang schauen der
um Russland herum liegt das heißt wir
wissen zum Beispiel nicht wie steht es
eigentlich um ihre Munitionsvorräte wir
haben Annahmen darüber aber wir können
die nicht letzten Endes prüfen das
andere ist dass wir natürlich auch sehen
was momentan an Munition in der Ukraine
verbraucht wird und das sind einfach
enorme Summen und die
Produktionskapazitäten viele westlicher
Staaten fangen das eigentlich nicht auf
das heißt wir haben da auch bald einen
sehr sehr großen Engpass und daran
ändert jetzt auch erstmal die Lieferung
dieser Panzer nicht viel generell ist es
tatsächlich so dass wir momentan
versuchen die Ukraine so zu stärken dass
sie die Linien halten kann und sie dann
eventuell eben auch in die Lage zu
versetzen wenn der Frühling kommt beide
seitenplaner wieder offensiven dass sie
dann vielleicht auch wieder in der Lage
sind tatsächlich sich mit ihrer eigenen
Offensive durchzusetzen
James der friedes wir haben leider nicht
mehr viel Zeit mit ihnen weil sie noch
in einen anderen wichtigen Termin müssen
aber hier sind noch diese zwei wichtigen
Fragen wir streiten jetzt hier über den
Leopard und ob die Deutschen in der
kampfpanzerdiskussion nun eine Führung
übernehmen und übernehmen müssen und der
Generalstabschef des US-amerikanischen
Heeres sagt es sieht nicht nach einem
militärischen Sieg der Ukraine aus
ich glaube das generell für eine sehr
ehrliche Einschätzung abgibt und
wahrscheinlich auch eine zutreffende
ganz besonders die Frage der Krim wird
sehr schwierig sein erst einmal gibt es
dort eine sehr pro russische
Bevölkerungsmehrheit ihn auf der Krim
die Russen sind dort verfestet es gibt
eine sehr starke emotionale Bindung auch
in der Krim anders als an anderen Orten
dieser 800 Meilen langen Freund das wird
also ein sehr sehr schwieriger Kampf
oder würde da hat General recht aber es
gibt noch weitere Punkte nämlich erst
einmal dass der Krieg unvorhersagbar ist
und ich glaube die nationale Geschichte
unserer aller Länder sagen uns das dass
sich die Dinge sehr schnell verändern
können und zweitens
konzentrieren wir uns
unsere Aufgaben und viele ihrer reden
und redenerinnen haben das schon
hervorgehoben unsere Aufgabe besteht
jetzt nicht darin die Bundeswehr zu
schicken und diesen Krieg zu kämpfen es
ist auch nicht dass die IT second
airborne Luft auf der Vereinigten
Staaten geschickt würde unsere Aufgabe
besteht darin die nötigen Instrumente an
die Ukraine weiter zu erreichen damit
sie diese Aufgabe erfüllen können damit
sie stark genug sind so dass wenn dann
die Verhandlungen anstellen und ich sage
ihm irgendwann wird verhandelt werden
dass sie in der stärksten möglichen
Position sind um so viel von ihrem
Territorium auch zurück zu verlangen wie
nur möglich und wenn diese Verhandlung
dann anstehen wissen wir natürlich auch
noch nicht wie sie ausgehen aber ich
glaube das im Laufe der Zeit wir in
diese Positionen der Ukraine aus
positivste verändern und stärken können
und ich möchte noch einmal betonen dass
es mir wirklich eine Freude war hier bei
Ihnen als Gast zu sein in meiner Zeit
als natokumentären vier Jahre war ich
sehr häufig in Europa auch auf meinem
Weg nach Afghanistan und dort
ich auch immer mit den verschiedenen
Verteidigungsministern Ministerinnen
zusammengearbeitet auch mit Ursula von
der Leyen und ich bin nach wie vor ihrem
in Freundschaft verbunden und ich habe
sehr sehr warme Gefühle und Erinnerungen
an ihre Länder an ihre Streitkräfte auch
an die Bundeswehr vielen Dank noch
einmal für die Einladung ja erstmal
danke es war großartig Sie bei uns zu
haben aus great to have you Withers und
vielen Dank dass wir mit Ihnen all diese
schweren Gedanken teilen dürfen was wir
und jetzt in der Runde natürlich auch
weitermachen werden Frau Rosenthal wir
sind bei den Leopards wir sind bei der
Frage wie ein Bundeskanzler entscheidet
wenn die Polen nun sagen sie möchten mit
einer Gruppe von europäischen Ländern
ein Kontingent Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung
stellen und der Bundeskanzler muss das
genehmigen wie wird das entscheiden
also ich glaube erstmal ist es wichtig
noch mal darauf zu verweisen dass wir ja
nicht erst mit den Mardern jetzt
angefangen haben Waffen zu liefern
sondern ich möchte schon immer wieder
auch darauf hinweisen wenn man sich die
Liste anguckt wie liefern ja immer
wieder Material nach und das ist glaube
ich auch genau das was mit
kontinuierlicher Unterstützung und
Solidarität gemeint ist denn gerade am
Anfang wurde die Ukraine ja oft schon
abgeschrieben nach dem Motto das ist eh
nicht leistbar und das was die Ukraine
leistet ist unfassbar mit welchem Mut
sie da sich selbst verteidigen natürlich
ist die Bundesregierung weitergefordert
sind wir alle gefordert als Land diese
Solidarität aufrecht zu erhalten und von
daher ist für mich wichtig und auch für
die SPD das wir es abstimmen und ich
muss ehrlich sagen mein Verständnis von
abstimmen ist nicht das Dinge in der
Presse kommuniziert werden sondern ich
glaube Abstimmung verläuft vor allem so
dass man sich miteinander berät und dann
gemeinsam agiert und ich glaube das muss
dann auch der Maßstab sein indem man zum
Beispiel europäisch miteinander
verhandelt aber natürlich wenn die
Entscheidung auf dem Tisch liegt und
Polen jetzt seinerseits diese Anfrage an
Deutschland stellt dann wird sie geprüft
und dann wird sie entschieden nach den
Maßstäben die bisher auch galten keine
Alleingänge zu machen zu gucken was es
nötig und dann habe ich schon gesagt hat
dass wir uns schwer dagegen aber
vielleicht können wir mal schnell hören
warum es um den Leoparden jetzt gerade
geht und wer sich dazu schon wie
geäußert hat
er ist das Kronjuwel der Bundeswehr und
patrouilliert bereits in Litauen
nichts will die Ukraine mehr als den
Leopard 2
bislang blockierte Deutschland
jetzt will Polen den Kampfpanzer nach
Kiew liefern und Berlin soll es
genehmigen denn wer Marder sagt der sagt
auch irgendwann Leopard und entsprechend
sollte Deutschland sich nicht in den Weg
stellen wenn andere Länder
Entscheidungen treffen die Ukraine zu
unterstützen ich würde mir wünschen dass
als
hauptherstellungsland von Leopard 2 wir
in die europäische Initiative am Staaten
für die Lieferung von Leopard 2 und da
ist sind die Grünen und es gibt einen
entsprechendes FDP Zitat natürlich auch
nicht nur von marie-ag Zimmermann Herr
Röttgen wir sind bei der Frage wie lange
denken sie wird der Bundeskanzler das
noch halten können dass auch die Frage
nach den Leopards auf die
Bundesregierung zuläuft mal unabhängig
von der polnischen bitte
also ist ja schon lange da es wird schon
lange verweigert
es gab auch schon vorher Länder die das
tun wollten aber die haben schon immer
also Spanien und andere Länder die haben
schon immer im Vorfeld gehört von der
Bundesregierung und zwar von einem Teil
der Bundesregierung denn sie haben die
Teile zitiert FDP für den Grünen die
dafür sind auch schon seit längerem
haben den immer signalisiert wir werden
diese Genehmigung nicht erteilen weil
das deutsche Produkte sind muss also
auch die Bundesregierung diesen weiter
Exporten zustimmen und ich glaube es
wird so laufen wie es beim Marder
gelaufen ist dass das der Vorwand des
allein Gangs den wir angeblich
ausschließen wollen den glaubt ja keiner
jeder weiß ja dass die Lage anders ist
es ist der deutsche Alleingang der
Alleingang des Kanzlers etwas zu
verweigern wenn es kein wenn es Dir
nicht gibt frage ich immer mit welcher
Position spricht eigentlich die
Bundesregierung mit den Polen oder mit
den Briten oder mit den Franzosen was
ist eigentlich die Position der
Bundesregierung wenn man keinen
da muss man doch eine Position haben und
die ist um dies strittig der Kanzler
sagt ich will es nicht nicht weil das
was mit Eskalation zu tun hat nach
meiner Auffassung sondern weil es mit
seinen Russland politischen
Vorstellungen nicht den Übereinstimmung
steht und der andere Teil der Regierung
will es nicht dass der wahre Grund und
alles alle anderen sind vorgeschobene
Gründe jetzt aber zu Ihrer Frage ich
glaube
das was wir eben diskutiert haben
es ist eben in diesen Wochen Monaten
würde ich fast sagen sichtbar geworden
dass wenn wir nicht jenseits aller
Waffensysteme wenn wir der Ukraine nicht
das mögliche und nötige geben
dann wird das ein lang andauerndes
Blutbad geben das was wir jetzt im
bachmut Erleben auf beiden Seiten auf
russischer Seite wahrscheinlich Faktor
drei vier fünf von den von den
ukrainischen Toten jeden Tag das wird
fürchterlich werden und wir werden es
nicht unter Kontrolle kriegen wir werden
auch keinen Weg zum Frieden finden wenn
nicht die Ukraine in die Lage versetzt
wird militärisch erfolgreich zu sein
dann wird es keine politische Lösung
geben und vor der Alternative steht man
jetzt es so laufen zu lassen oder die
Ukraine so zu unterstützen das Politik
möglich wird und ich glaube der Druck
wird so groß werden das um das Rammstein
Treffen in der nächsten Woche es dann
sehr schnell gehen wird bis dahin dass
die Bundesregierung der Bundeskanzler
diesen Widerstand nicht aufrechterhalten
kann wenn man allein mal sich wenn man
alleine mal sich vergegenwärtig wie in
den letzten 24 bis 48 Stunden sich die
die Sprache der Regierung verändert hat
also
habe gesagt jetzt ganz klar wir stehen
nicht mehr im Wege von europäischen
Lösungen man würde sich wünschen dass
wir die europäische Lösung herbeiführen
aber mindestens dürfen sie doch nicht
vereiteln der europäische Lösung es gibt
keine roten Linien noch nicht einmal
mehr beim SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzenden also
das Tor ist geöffnet worden dafür dass
der Druck so groß wird und dass man dann
sagen kann jetzt ist es ja kein
Alleingang mehr jetzt sind die anderen
auch dafür dass so glaube ich wird die
Entwicklung sein ob das in der nächsten
Woche schon sein wird würde ich eher
vermuten das war natürlich vor Rosental
ist gleich dran ich würde jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz den Spiegel Kollegen fragen
wollen nach genau sie sind gleich dran
nach genau dieser These ist es denn
wirklich so dass um Deutschland herum
eigentlich alle immer wollten dass wir
von Anfang an alles Militärische Gerät
auf den Tisch packen entschuldigung wenn
ich das noch mal Nachfrage oder hat es
nicht auch in Frankreich große Bedenken
gegeben in anderen Ländern bedenken
gegeben da erst recht in einen langen
aufwendigen Krieg zu gehen das muss man
zu Hause ja auch erklären können
es gab da bestimmt verschiedene Phasen
das würde ich ganz klar sagen aber ich
würde schon denken dass seit dem Sommer
letzten Jahres
ich sehe das immer etwas sozusagen
pragmatischer ich bin ja kein Politiker
sondern ich beobachte ja so auf der
einen Seite was Politiker machen und
dann auf der anderen Seite was dann auch
technisch einfach laufen muss und das
was jetzt passieren müsste aus meiner
Sicht ist dass sich auf der einen Seite
Olaf Scholz mit seinem Team zusammen
hinsetzt und die Europäer versucht
zusammenzuholen so diskret wie möglich
damit genau das aufhört jetzt diese
polnischen Forscher der polnische
Forschung ist im Prinzip aus meiner
Sicht nur ein Trigger weil die Polen
sozusagen die wissen das ist ein
Reizpunkt wenn Sie das sozusagen jetzt
nach vorne bringen dann auch mit dieser
Genehmigung und wenn wir uns mal zurück
erinnern an die Tage nach dem 24 Februar
hatten wir eine ganz ähnliche Situation
damals sind auch Länder auf uns
zugekommen haben damals schon gesagt wir
wollen ähm Haubitzen liefern die aus
deutscher Produktion kommen das hat
Deutschland erst abgelehnt und dann als
der Druck zu groß war wurde die erste
Genehmigung erteilt das war dieser
berühmte Samstag vor der Zeitenwende
Rede und dann gehen innerhalb von
Stunden vielen dann auch andere Tabus
und deswegen deswegen würde ich mir
wünschen dass auf der einen Seite diese
politischen Gespräche geführt werden und
das muss auch möglich sein ich glaube
das Olaf Scholz dazu auch in der Lage
ist mit seinen Leuten und auf der
anderen Seite glaube ich was wir
dringend brauchen und das sieht man ja
bei der marderentscheidung dass man es
jetzt auch schon technisch vorbereitet
das heißt dass man auch wieder diskret
mit der Industrie spricht sagt was habt
ihr eigentlich was könntet ihr innerhalb
von kurzer Zeit sozusagen wieder instand
setzen und das hat mich schon ein
bisschen enttäuscht ehrlich gesagt
nachdem wir mitbekommen hatten es gibt
jetzt eine Wende beim Marder als ich
dann am gleichen Tag noch hören muss es
ist technisch nichts vorbereitet und das
war ja ein regelrechtes Chaos dann dann
hieß es erst Frau Lambrecht sagt
natürlich gut klar will sie natürlich
keine Marder hergeben die braucht sich
selber dringend weil sie einfach das ist
ein wichtiges Waffensystem und es hatte
aber auch niemand mit der Bundeswehr
richtig geredet hatte niemand mit der
Industrie gesprochen und dann ist
griechen gerettet weil sie gesagt haben
sie verzichten auf die 20 das heißt
diese Idee und auch die Vorstellung
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz würde vor
allen Dingen gründlich abwägen gut
vorausplanen also wie würden sie das
funktionieren wenn sie es müssen es
fehlt nicht am Impuls aber es fehlt an
einer concealen Vorbereitung so
das ist glaube ich darüber haben wir ja
schon also oft geschrieben und
Kommentare geschrieben auch im das war
schon im April Mai Juni haben wir immer
wieder darauf hingewiesen und das auch
genau beschrieben bereitet die Lieferung
wenigstens vor so dass wenn die
politische Entscheidung fällt dass wir
dann vorbereitet sind nichts davon ist
passiert und meine Befürchtung ist dass
ich jetzt beim Leopard ähnlich ist weil
es ist auch nicht so die Bundeswehr ist
nicht so gut ausgestattet auch die
polnischen Leopards übrigens müssten
wahrscheinlich noch mal nach Deutschland
in den standsetzung weil die gar nicht
richtig aktiv in der polnischen Armee
sind aber ich will noch mal auf einen
Punkt zurückkommen weil sie gefragt
haben sozusagen was sind die
europäischen Erwartungen an oder Scholz
oder an Deutschland die ist glaube ich
ganz klar dass Deutschland Führung
übernimmt und das ist auch das was die
USA erwarten die da drängen uns nicht
sozusagen liefert Waffen macht das lasst
euch sozusagen bestimmen sondern die USA
und das ist ja nicht erst sozusagen seit
jetzt der Ukraine Konflikt noch mal so
eskaliert ist das war auch schon 2014 so
hat Barbara Obama den Europäern und zwar
damals Angela Merkel im Prinzip die
Verantwortung in die Hand gegeben hat
gesagt Angela das ist ein Konflikt der
bei dir in Europa spielt wir
unterstützen dich natürlich aber das ist
eigentlich was was ihr und die Franzosen
Regeln ist und die Frustration wenn man
die mit alten Obama Leuten redet wie das
dann sozusagen sage ich mal nicht
richtig gemacht wurde Angela Merkel hat
sich ja kürzlich auch noch mal geäußert
am Ende hätte sie dann die Kraft nicht
mehr gehabt politisch ich sage nur das
ist eigentlich eher die Erwartung es
geht gar nicht so konkret darum und so
ist das Verhältnis Deutschland USA im
Moment nicht mehr dass man so wie Trump
sozusagen nach draußen sagt ihr seid
Loser und ihr könnt es nicht entscheiden
sondern das macht man sozusagen in
Gesprächen aber die Amerikaner erwarten
schon dass nach so welchen Gesprächen
dann eben auch in Europa behandelt wird
und das Olaf Scholz diese Führungsrolle
übernehmen und da sind wir jetzt endlich
bei Frau Rosenthal sie haben schon damit
gerechnet dass dieser Ball jetzt wieder
zu ihnen rollt wann würden sie denken
ist das eine gute Situation dass die
Deutschen dass dieser Bundeskanzler vor
Rosenthal Führung übernimmt machen wir
das dann erst wenn es einen
Friedensschluss gibt oder also ich sehe
überhaupt nicht dass es keinerlei
Führung gibt von Seiten des
Bundeskanzlers und ich muss eine Sache
einfach wie kann ich nicht
unwidersprochen lassen das ist das immer
wieder unterstellt wird auch gerade von
der CDU das Olaf Scholz und vor allem
die SPD als Ganzes die Ukraine nicht
100%ig unterstützen und an ihrer Seite
stehen das stimmt einfach nicht das tun
wir das kann man nachlesen an allein an
Mitteln was die Bundesregierung
bereitgestellt hat man kann abwägen ob
das reicht man kann darüber diskutieren
ob man Schritt weitergehen kann weil man
darf nicht in Frage stellen ob das der
Fall ist und wenn es darum geht was
führung bedeutet dann glaube ich sind da
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen von
einfach vorhanden ist Führung vor oder
ist Führung das was sie auch beschrieben
haben zu sagen man versucht diskret
miteinander zu organisieren wie man es
macht und ich würde schon sagen auch
wenn natürlich es unglücklich war das
macron vorgeprescht ist was dann diese
panzerlieferung angeht da gab es ja eine
Abstimmung und deshalb sehe ich darin
genau den Beweis dessen was immer wieder
gesagt wurde es gibt eine Abstimmung
müssen wir darüber reden wie die
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa
insgesamt aufgestellt ist und was
Deutschland dort auch tun muss und nicht
tun muss und wie wir das besser
organisieren müssen und gerade nach
vorne raus ist da jetzt noch mal der
besondere Fokus drauf ja auf jeden Fall
und natürlich ist auch Deutschland als
einer der großen Länder ganz besonders
gefordert nur ich verstehe Führung nicht
so dass einer vorgeht und sagt so machen
wir es sondern ich glaube gerade Europa
ist dann erfolgreich wenn man sich
miteinander jetzt haben wir
wahrscheinlich so oder so also
wahrscheinlich haben wir jetzt so oder
so diese Schlüsselrolle weil wir ja
genehmigungspflichtig sind für
beispielsweise diesen Leopard aber ich
wollte auf die Führungsrolle noch mal
kommen 100 sie haben auf dem JUSO
Kongress interessanterweise gesagt dass
sie damit ein echtes Problem haben und
wahrscheinlich nicht nur sie schauen ich
glaube nicht und ich bin der festen
Überzeugung und werde mich da auch mit
allen Mitteln wehren dass es richtig ist
zu sagen wir sind eine Führungsmacht
oder wir sind übernehmen Führung das
sagst ja nicht nur du es ist und bleibt
einfach falsch
so das ist im November des letzten
Jahres gewesen sehen Sie das heute
anders nein ich sehe das heute ganz
genauso die Fraktion auch nicht sondern
würde sie sich heute auch anders
geäußert haben in ihrem Papier zum Krieg
denn der Begriff Führungsmacht und da
sind wir genau bei dem Thema was ich
gerade angesprochen habe beinhaltet für
mich das Deutschland vorgeht wie wir es
z.B gesehen haben in der ganzen Frage
der aussteritätspolitik des
kaputtsparens Europas wo fast Europa
verbrochen ist da Deutschland auch allen
Leuten gesagt wie wie es der laufen soll
und ich sag mal so die
Begeisterung auch bis heute ist in den
europäischen Nachbarländern nicht gerade
groß was das angeht deshalb ist für mich
Führungsrolle übernehmen im Sinne von
Verantwortung übernehmen ja das muss
Deutschland machen Führungsmacht im
Sinne von alleine nach vorne gehen und
sagen so wird es jetzt gemacht das ist
aus meiner Perspektive nicht
Deutschlands Rolle sondern wir müssen es
im Verbund miteinander machen und das
sieht man ja jetzt auch wer hätte
gedacht dass in diesem Angriffskrieg
Europa so zusammenhält und das hat
natürlich auch was mit Arbeit zu tun die
gemacht worden ist auch politische
Arbeit auch von unserem Kanzler auch vom
Kanzler wir sind bei Frau deitelhoff in
Frankfurt und Fragen genau das noch mal
nach Frau deidelhoff erwarten die
Amerikaner das hat unser Gebauer gerade
gesagt dass wir diese Führungsrolle
übernehmen und müsste jetzt also der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz das was die
Polen gerade Tun übernehmen und sagen
ich organisiere diese europäische
Initiative um den Leo zu haben zu tragen
also ich glaube was die Amerikaner
erwarten ist das europa-führung
übernimmt und gar nicht so konkretes
muss durch Island richten sondern dass
die Europäer sozusagen die eigenen
Sicherheitsprobleme in die Hand nehmen
und das passiert sicher nicht genug was
diese Frage jetzt
darum geht es gar nicht ich glaube es
geht darum dass die Europäer als
Europäer nicht nur macron nicht nur
Scholz sondern dass man zu gemeinsamen
Lösungen hier findet und nicht immer
darauf wartet dass die USA einem sagt
wie man es denn zu tun hätte ich glaube
das ist die Erwartung aber es geht nicht
darum dass Scholz sozusagen jetzt die
führungsmarkt symbolisiert ich muss
sagen ich finde auch diese Debatte
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich ermüdend also
die führen wir jetzt auch seit 11
Monaten ob Deutschland jetzt sozusagen
und die deutsche Bundesregierung die
sozialdemokratischer Teil dieser
Bundesregierung jetzt irgendwie
diejenigen sind die die ganze Zeit auf
der Bremse stehen alle Zahlen die wir
haben sagen doch etwas ganz anderes die
sagen dass Deutschland nach den USA
eigentlich zu den stärksten
Unterstützern der Ukraine gehört jetzt
kann man darüber reden ob das immer
schnell genug ist und ob sozusagen die
Sorge vor Eskalation irgendwie zu stark
ist aber nichtsdest du weniger hat es
diese Unterstützung und hat die
Bundesregierung auch alle diese
Unterstützung gebracht es ist im Grunde
genommen eine verlorene Debatte das
sieht man ja immer wieder es kommt immer
wieder das gleiche Argument wenn dann
Anlieferung kommt heißt es immer aber er
hätte die doch schon im Sommer wäre die
doch schon da gewesen hat würde die
Ukraine heute ganz ehrlich diskutieren
aber man hat eben eine Abwägung
vorgenommen viel spannender finde ich
die Frage ob wir mit dem was wir
momentan haben nämlich den Marder
Ankündigung werden wir damit tatsächlich
eine Kehrtwende schaffen beziehungsweise
die Ukraine wieder in die Vorderhand
bringen oder werden wir letzten Endes
eben sozusagen nur diesen
abnutzungskrieg in dem wir uns
gegenwärtig befinden werden wir den
damit nur verlängern und das ist ja die
spannende Frage ja das ist eine
spannende Frage und ich stelle sie ihnen
auch gleich oder Sie haben sie sich
selber gestellt aber zunächst werden wir
ja auch von der Realität überrollt und
zwar hier von einer europäischen
Realität nämlich dass unsere Verbündeten
erst recht die osteuropäischen sagen
jetzt kommt mal langsam in die Strümpfe
das muss ich Ihnen ja eigentlich nicht
sagen also wir zitieren ja nicht uns
selbst sondern wir zitieren unsere
wichtigsten Verbündeten aber hier ist
die Frage wird sich jetzt mit dem Marder
nennenswert etwas in an der Lage im
Boden ändern die sie die wir alle vorhin
von ihnen allen so präzise beschrieben
bekommen haben
ja ich glaube da haben wir ein paar der
wesentlichen Stichworte eben genannt
also mit 40 Mardern wird sich natürlich
so viel nicht ändern können was wir
haben wird dann wahrscheinlich sozusagen
zumindest werden wir wieder einen ein
materialgerät zwischen ukrainischem
Bodentruppen und dem Feind haben und das
ist dringend nötig damit die durchhalten
können es wird nicht dafür ausreichen
dass sie tatsächlich wieder Gelände
Gewinne machen können dafür braucht es
tatsächlich mehr dann kommt die Frage
der Leopard oder anderer Kampfpanzer
aber sagen wir mal der Leopard 2 die
brauchen aber eine enorme Zeit bis sie
überhaupt irgendwann auf dem
Schlachtfeld dort tatsächlich vorhanden
sind und bedienbar sind das heißt dass
alles sozusagen kostet natürlich auch
einiges an Zeit und das ist glaube ich
eine Frage der für uns natürlich
aufstellen müssen also sind wir
eigentlich in der Lage so zu
unterstützen dass die Ukraine in der
Lage ist ihre Grenzen von 1991 wieder
zurück zur erobern und ich bin da
ehrlich gesagt nach all dem was wir
momentan sehen eher skeptisch
1991 ist ja auch ein neues Stil wer das
ruft jetzt die Ukraine aus wir haben
diskutiert im Ende des letzten Jahres
dass man den Status quo ante von eben
dem 23.2 des letzten Jahres wieder
erreicht die Ukraine behaupten jetzt
natürlich etwas anderes denken sie denn
dass man in der Ukraine diese wir holen
uns die ganzen Gebiete wieder zurück
glaubt
also ich glaube was passiert es ist dass
man zumindest das so stark öffentlich
immer wieder ausgerufen hat immer mehr
wiederholt hat dass man gar nicht mehr
dahinter zurückkommt also ich glaube
eine Regierung selenski die öffentlich
ankündigen würde sie ist bereit die Krim
aufzugeben oder sie ist bereit
gebietsabtretung in dornbas vorzunehmen
würde das politische schlicht und
einfach nicht überleben interessant das
ist eine interessante These das heißt
wir haben im Grunde Katrin Eugendorf
wichtige Frage auch an sie glauben die
Ukraine dass es gelingen wird diese
Rückeroberungen zu schaffen erst recht
in Anbetracht der jetzigen Situation
wenn man sich anschaut wie die Ukraine
im Grunde von den Russen jeden Tag
überfallen und bombardiert werden ich
würde sagen das ist im Moment für die
Ukraine nicht das wichtigste Thema im
Moment was wir in der Ukraine sehen ist
wirklich ein Überlebenskampf und zwar
sowohl auf militärische Seite aber auch
in der Zivilbevölkerung das heißt die
Frage erobern wir irgendwann die Krim
zurück ist kein Thema das in der
ukrainischen Öffentlichkeit diskutiert
wird ich denke die Frage der Krim ist
eine entscheidende weil es würde Sinn
machen die Krim abzutreten
aber es ist natürlich betrachtet aus
seiner mal dem Endpunkt eine möglichen
vielleicht Friedensvertrag für die
Ukrainer fatal wenn Sie das tun würden
denn es geht ja letztendlich darum dem
Land weiterhin auf Dauer Sicherheits zu
garantieren und die Ukraine wird
irgendwann wenn es und dieser Krieg wird
auf dem Verhandlungsweg gelöst werden
müssen wird sicherheitsförderung stellen
und wie soll denn dann die
Sicherheitsarchitektur für eine
nachkriegsukraine Aussehen wir haben
gelebt erlebt dass unsere
Verträge mindest eins und mindest zwei
die Ukraine geschwächt haben deutlich
geschwächt haben weil von den
Territorien die Russland besetzt hat ja
den Don Bass die Krim vor allem jetzt
maßgebliche Angriffe gegen die Ukraine
verübt werden und deswegen hatte ja auch
Russland das Interesse Krim zu besetzen
und den Donbass zu besetzen das heißt
ich denke wir müssen unsere Strategie
unser Verhalten in diesem Krieg ein
bisschen Loslösen von diesem kleinen
liefern willst diese Waffe jene Waffe
macht der dies macht Jena das und mal
ein Kriegsziel definieren welche
Stellung will denn der Westen in diesem
Krieg einnehmen und da kann doch nicht
das Ziel alleine sein zu sagen wir
ermöglichen der Ukraine jetzt ihr
Territorium zu verteidigen oder
vielleicht auch zurückzukommen die Frage
standhalten oder Rückgewinnung da sind
wir jetzt im Grunde nicht mehr
militärisch sondern angebliche Frage für
mich ist die maßgebliche Frage
geht darüber hinaus wir müssen Russland
damit reinholen unser Ziel muss doch
sein dieses russische Regime daran zu
hindern weiter in dieser Art und Weise
kriegt zu führen denn es ist ja nicht
nur ein Krieg gegen die Ukraine ist ein
Krieg gegen die westliche Welt
und das findet mir bei diesen Debatten
zu wenig zu wenig ja Raum diese Frage
denn wenn wir dazu kommen dass wir sagen
unser Ziel ist Russland so weit
zurückzuwerfen dass es diese Kriege
nicht mehr führen kann dann müssen wir
viel beherzter und viel klarer die
Ukraine mit waffenausstatten und
übrigens auch dafür sorgen dass der
Luftraum der Ukraine gesichert wird
nicht nur nicht nur der Boden ja wir
haben darüber auch schon diskutiert Herr
Röttgen ist gleich dran Herr Gebauer
auch noch mal mit der Frage wann
entsteht dieses Part wo beide Seiten
nicht mehr glauben dass sie vor allen
Dingen mit dem Krieg sich die bessere
Position erarbeiten sondern mit
Verhandlungen bessere Situationen
Arbeiten darüber kann man nachdenken
wenn wir uns die Frage stellen wohin
eigentlich unsere Kriegsziel bestehen
jetzt ist die große Frage was muss man
tun damit man zu diesem schrecklichen
Platz kommt und dieses hat von Putin
übrigens auch als ein paar verstanden
wird
also ich ziehe einen anderen Schluss aus
dem Eigendorf gesagt hat als sie sie
sagen ja jetzt die schlussfolgend aus
ist das schreckliche Pat herbeizuführen
und dann kommt das Einsehen bei der
Seiten meine Einschätzung ist dass das
Patt weiterseiten beide Seiten in diesen
Krieg verstrickt und eine politische
Lösung auch eine Verhandlungslösung
verhindert für Putin gibt es keinen Weg
zurück aus einem Patt heraus für
Zielinski und die Ukraine die so viele
Tote schon zu beklagen haben so viel
Zerstörung erlebt haben die können nicht
sagen jetzt ist Pat und wir verhandeln
jetzt weil es sie ja auch in der
Position der Schwäche zementieren würde
und darum sehe ich die Alternative genau
etwas anders nämlich das Desaster ist
das Part
und die andere Variante eine Alternative
ist und die einzige ich sage das so die
einzige um zu einer Friedenslösung in
Europa zu kommen ist der militärische
Erfolg der Ukraine ist der aus meiner
Sicht einzig Erfolg und darum stimme ich
ihn vor allem zu dass das die politische
Debatte ist ob das Marder heißt Leopard
Mick Luftraum das sind militärische
Fachfragen die politische Vorgabe ist
unser Ziel ist alles und mögliche für
den ukrainischen von militärischen
Erfolg zu tun das ist die eigentlich
politische Friedensfrage fragen wir
gleich Frau dadelhoff noch mal und
vorher vor Rosenthal Saskia esken meldet
sich heute zu Wort Frau Rosenthal und
sagt genau das zur Überraschung der
SPD-Spitze die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg
gewinnen hat sie damit auch sie
überrascht
eigentlich nicht weil ich dieser Meinung
auch bin und sagen auch die Ukraine muss
die Frage ist was ist gewinnen und die
Frage ist verhandeln wir an diesem Tisch
was das bedeutet ist das nicht die
Ukraine selbst die das definiert aber
wir stehen an der Seite der Ukraine und
deshalb müssen wir auch ganz klar
akzeptieren was sie als Gewinn für sich
definieren und müssen an ihrer Seite
stehen indem wir Sie unterstützen und
das ist ja und das ist übrigens da nicht
nur militärisch das ist auch mit
humanitärer Hilfe das ist übrigens auch
mit Schwächung Russland über
wirtschaftliche Sanktion ich bin mir z.B
nicht sicher ob wir diese
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen schon alle
ausgeschöpft haben weil auch da müssen
wir ja Russland noch weiter schwächen
auch da ist sicherlich noch einiges zu
tun